hey guys I'm Erik Bosse and the news
show Legion just premiered on FX and
this show is wild you're just staring at
the TV for an hour like I don't fully
understand what I'm watching and has so
many questions but everything looks
awesome and I love it
now if you haven't seen the premiere yet
trust me you gotta watch it this show
has so much going on on so many levels
and I need someone to talk about it with
so go go go go go go go okay so in this
video I'm gonna explain what this show
is and why it has the potential to be
the best new show of 2017 maybe the best
superhero series on TV right now and I'm
gonna dig deep into this first episode
try to answer some of the big questions
and point out some interesting stuff
that you might have missed so let's
start with what is legion or really the
question is who is legion so legion
David Haller is a character from the
x-men comics that's right even though it
looks very different Legion is another
TV adaptation of a Marvel comic series
but this show is very different from
daredevil and the other Netflix shows
and then agents of shield like for one
it's not part of the MCU it's on the Fox
Marvel side of things and really there
are just a lot of things that make
Legion unique to the genre that I'll
touch on in a bit so Legion is an
omega-level mutant which means he's one
of the most powerful mutants arguably
more powerful than Phoenix and he has
the ability to absorb other people's
psyches into his mind as alternate
identities allowing him if they're
mutant to use that identities powers as
well now on the surface this takes the
form of a mental disorder like
schizophrenia but he is actually a very
powerful mutant with telepathic and
telekinetic powers and in the comics
Legion has upwards of several thousand
split identities and the name Legion
originates from a Bible story where
Jesus approached a man possessed by many
evil spirits and asked his name and the
man replied I am legion for we are many
now I haven't mentioned perhaps the most
interesting part of legions backstory
and it's pretty common knowledge but you
can skip to this time in case the show
is saving it as a reveal and he don't
want to be spoiled
okay so Legion David holler is the son
of Charles Xavier thus explaining his
advanced telepathic abilities now
producers have said that they really
would like to explore David's
relationship with his father at some
point but there aren't
any plans for Patrick Stewart or James
McAvoy to appear on the show anytime
soon in fact John Landgraf of FX and
Legion creator Noah Holly have insisted
that this show will not be part of the
same cinematic universe as the x-men
movies so unlike how the Netflix Marvel
shows and agents of shield reference
events and characters in the MCU Legion
takes place in a parallel universe to
the x-men timeline or timelines there's
a lot of confusing stuff going on in
movies so I'm guessing there aren't
gonna be any Hugh Jackman or Deadpool
cameos sorry guys but in my opinion that
is a good thing because Noah Hawley is
kind of a genius when it comes to
anthology series he created Fargo for FX
as well which is a show that you should
definitely watch I think Holly is at his
best when he can build his own world in
mythology while using the theme and the
tone to stay true to the source material
so like how on a second season of Fargo
it expands to some trippy sci-fi stuff
it still feels part of the cruel and
darkly funny world established by the
Coen brothers in the original Fargo
movie and I think that is what no Hawley
is doing here with Legion it's a bold
intimate exploration of the complex mind
of one of the most interesting
superheroes and it's less concerned with
common superhero movie tropes like
saving the world or altering timelines
and while there aren't as many little
winks and references to the Marvel
Comics trust me
Holly's visual style is filled with
miscible details and all kinds of hidden
meanings so let's talk about this first
episode chapter 1 what the hell is going
on so the purpose of this first episode
is to introduce us to David Haller by
taking us inside his mind showing us the
world from his point of view but the
thing is because David's unique mental
state his perception of the world is
chaotic he's an unreliable narrator he
struggles to know whether what he's seen
is real or not
so we struggle to follow the logical
progression of the story so don't worry
if this episode seemed a bit
disorienting that's all by design but
the show uses lots of other cool
aesthetic choices to convey to us what's
going on and I'll bring those up as we
go
so these opening images already give us
a clue about what kind of mind we're
dealing with showing us this upward shot
of tree branches that split the sky like
tiny cracks and shattered glass now this
is a point of view shot from David as a
baby and I think this is meant to
reflect David
pattern identities and the montage that
follows is set to the song happy jack by
the who showing us this baby growing up
from a blissfully happy jack into a very
disturbed David this crowd of people
represents the dozens of identities
already crowding David split psyche and
we actually get a callback to this
screaming in the zero later on in the
episode and David psychiatrist's office
and I definitely didn't see this the
first time I watched it but check this
out the moment David puts his head in
the court News who is that passed in in
the background that is the devil with
the yellow eyes now he keeps showing up
throughout this episode as a terrifying
hallucination in David's mind I think as
a manifestation of his fear now I'll
talk more about this theory later but
yeah very creepy now I love two things
about this transition here the sparkler
candle wick superimposes over the new
scores and for a second it looks like a
dynamite views suggesting that David is
an explosive ready to go off which he
definitely does this episode but also
notice how the chord bisects the frame
into two halves now Noah Holly returns
to this dividing line over and over
throughout this episode including
seconds later with the barrier between
Amy and David so why does no how they do
this well for one this recurring
symmetry just looks very cool and it
gives a visual order to a story that's
very disordered but I also think this is
intended to match the symmetry of the
two halves of the human brain like every
frame is showing us David's mind with
the various voices on each side of it
talking to each other and real quick I
love the little joke Holly snuck into
the set of this visitor room the walls
are covered with the word welcome in
various languages there's English and
Spanish and also Swahili and Hawaiian
and Welsh as like the show is using
several different identities to welcome
us to the show of légion now the name of
this hospital is clockworks psychiatric
hospital which is a clever reference
because everyone in this hospital wears
orange and a Clockwork Orange is a
famous film by Stanley Kubrick about a
similarly disturbed man who undergoes
extreme psychological treatment now
Stanley Kubrick was famous as a
filmmaker for challenging the viewer
resisting the urge to tell a simple
story and instead using beautiful shot
composition and surreal imagery to shock
and a nervous using camerawork and
editing to make us feel what it's like
to go insane similar to what no Hawley
is doing in this episode and really if
you're looking closely Kubrick is a huge
influence on this episode now this may
just be a coincidence but I think the
circular design of this hospital room
with the sterile white surfaces and
artificial light and a central part and
the way David initially spins around it
it feels like it's all meant to evoke
the famous jogging shot in Kubrick's
2001 a Space Odyssey now Lenny whose
opera plazas character was initially
written to be a male character but when
Halle met Plaza here II thought the role
still a Plaza insisted that they keep
most of the dialogue the same because
she wanted to play the part with
ambiguous gender inspired by David Bowie
did you that were me all day we also
meet Sydney Barrett who has to cover
herself and avoid skin contact which
sounds a lot like rogue but in Sid's
case it's because touching someone swaps
her consciousness into their body and
vice versa and that's what happens later
in this episode when she and David kiss
and by the way her name Syd Barrett is a
reference to Syd Barrett of Pink Floyd
whose psychedelic music was another
inspiration for the show apparently no
Holly assembled a 160 track playlist for
the cast to listen to which included a
lot of Pink Floyd as well as like
experimental French sound design and
people screaming into bins okay moving
on
these next two sequences give us a kind
of cipher for how to interpret David's
visions so the first shows him having a
nightmare in his room and notice how red
light is associated with bad frightening
memories colour coding is a big part of
the show and red specifically is used to
recall negative moments from David's
past also the voice of his psychiatrist
dr. Kissinger asks David about
definitely the otherwise and if you look
closely during this nightmare you can
kind of see the devil with the yellow is
haunting David again this figure is a
symbol of all of David's fears and it
comes to him during his darkest moments
so we learned two things here when the
color red shows up prominently something
bad is happening or is about to happen
and when the devil with the yellow eyes
appears David is paralyzed by his fear
but then after being sedated we see
David's visions in a more positive light
a pleasant memory with his sister and
his dog on a seashore shown through this
old school projector frame so we also
learn what it looks like when David's in
a place of calm and comfort images of
his sister from their childhoods the
outdoors and vivid colors and what I
like about this is this is really how
memory works right like it's a sensory
experience we don't remember the logic
of how everything went down we remember
the feeling of it was it an abrupt
uncomfortable feeling that we want to
try to forget or was it a nice Pleasant
feeling that we wanted to stretch on
forever so the shot composition in the
editing isn't intended to make sense on
a logical level but it does make a ton
of sense on an emotional level okay
moving on to this sequence when David
and Sydney's start dating notice how the
intense backlight merely obscures SIDS
face and I think this is implying that
David doesn't truly know Sydney yet he's
in love with her anyway Sydney Barrett
is a real woman but the version of her
that he's in love with is an illusion
that he's created and I love the use of
the Rolling Stones she's a rainbow which
is a song about being totally
head-over-heels infatuated with someone
obviously it's super fitting to hear
this song about rainbows as the show
hits us with so many colors the green
forest wall the orange hallway the blue
light at the end of the hallway and then
the yellow in the darker shade of blue
in the hospital window where they gaze
out and do this adorbs reflection kiss
but the thing about rainbows is they're
not like real and tangible they are
optical illusions created by light
shining through water particles so just
like how David saw Sydney as this
rainbow as the Sun shines through her
and I like how the show uses their
reflections kissing to reinforce this
point David and Sydney can't truly
embrace here their love is an illusion a
trick of the light
and again this show
uses red light to signal bad news as
David is shaken out of this moment back
into the present as he's being
interrogated and notice the set in this
interrogation room there's a massive red
table red chairs so this is obviously
not a safe place for David and in this
scene the episode reveals its nonlinear
structure so everything we've seen up
until now has taken place in flashback
inside David's fractured mind as he
tries to remember how he came into
clockworks hospital how he met Sidney
and how he got out and how physically
impossible deadly destruction happened
there and then notice how as the
interrogator leaves the room the camera
follows him for a long tracking shot
through this facility which looks kind
of like a former school and the
camerawork again gives us a clue for how
to interpret the reality of the show
because for the first time this episode
the camera leaves David's perspective
with a long shot showing us this place
in real time so we know everything we're
seeing here is real objective truth
everything else that David's memory is
compromised but we know for sure that
he's being held in a government facility
where his powers are being monitored and
since we know that this is all reality
we can interpret the weird stuff that we
see as legitimate mysteries so for
example what is the meaning of this
Domino looking symbol on the soldiers
uniforms in the video feed wire some of
them wearing pink hats what was the Red
Hook incident that they refer to after
what happened in Red Hook I'd say that's
an understatement and what is the
significance of the dog in the cage in
the monetary nerve now I don't have
answers to these yet but I do think
there's a connection between the dog and
the cage and the dog figurine that the
man in the green suit carves he leaves
it behind it's kind of a watchdog for
David and I think it's meant to convey
that these men mean David harm further
illustrating that this is not a safe
place for him okay moving on I like how
the read interrogation table connects
visually to the read counter tops of
David's kitchen in this negative memory
when a fight with his girlfriend caused
his telekinesis to explode and I got to
say the Legion premiere doesn't have
many superhero II spectacles but the
ones it does have look fantastic and
notice how for a second David seems to
enjoy this power but then the knife
graces him and he's suddenly fearful and
who shows up to manifest that fear the
devil with the yellow eyes
yeah now this is the best look we've
gotten at the devil's face and yikes
this guy seems like a cross between
butterball and Hellraiser and the yellow
bastard in Sin City
I also wonder if any inspiration was
taken from the yellow King and true
detective who was another fear incarnate
figure who hunted an anthology story but
whatever he is he's very effective as a
symbol of David's fear now something
interesting happens when David comes out
of the memory notice how his food tray
is gone and the dog figurine has been
turned in the other direction so has
David just been out for a long time or
is there more going on maybe with this
silent screen soup guy but when it comes
to this dog figurine I think it being
turned around implies that the tables
are turning here like before the
facility was a threat to David and now
he's a threat to all of them because he
remembers that he's not just a mental
patient he's an extremely powerful
mutant you're afraid of me now as David
returns to his memory of the day he
escaped notice the emphasis on the game
of ping pong now I like the parallelism
between the ball being swapped back and
forth across the table or shadowing
David in Sidney's Minds being swapped
between their bodies and when their
minds swap at the kiss I love the way
the visuals convey what's happening
first we get this microscopic close-up
of the surface of their lips as tiny
particles jump from her skin to his
implying her consciousness jumping into
his body
then from Sidney's point of view we see
David's memories on tiny screens in a
field and that connects back to our
first shot of Sidney's standing in front
of this painting of a field in the
hospital and then finally when they
paying back into consciousness all these
shots are upside down suggesting that
things that flipped between the two of
them so even though this cutaway scene
with David and the interrogator kind of
spells out literally what's going on the
information is all there in the visuals
so Sidney and David's body uses David's
powers to freak out and reconstruct the
hospital ceiling all the doors shut and
accidentally impaling Lenny and drywall
killing her and what does David and
Sidney's body do yeah
touches her boobs because it's the first
thing any guy would do and then yes
escape the hospital but boob touch first
meanwhile as David and the president
miss remembers the interrogator being
outside the hospital
show gives us a small but pretty
striking taste of his power stabbing the
interrogator in the face with a pen and
then obliterating everything in the room
and this all brings me to for me the
most confusing part of a very confusing
episode so back in David's memory we see
David and Sydney's body at a cafe with
that same bright green suitcase but then
it seems like Sydney's body swapping
power fades as David's childhood
memories overtake this moment and then
strangely instead of their
consciousnesses swapping back to
wherever their bodies are their bodies
swap back so that David's body gets to
join his mind free outside the hospital
and maybe this is just like another
delusion in David's mind but I'm hoping
future episodes give us more information
on how exactly Sydney's power works
because my mind is still trying to
process what happened here and I like
how the show actually calls out this
confusion over David's identity here
with this meta joke from the
trick-or-treater what are you supposed
to be yeah good question kid so David's
returned to his sister's home is
designed as a reconnect with that
opening montage of his childhood
so the nighttime shot of the tree
branches matches the opening shot and
then in the basement we see all these
objects that were from his childhood the
rocket constellation lamp the soccer
trophy and the tricycle now Lenny
appears to David as a hallucination
taunting him as a manifestation of his
guilt for his powers causing Lenny's
death and leaving Sydney behind in his
place in the hospital but then check out
this miserable detail after David breaks
the lamp you can see Lenny's ghostly
reflection in the mirror staring at
David as he lies to his sister okay
moving on to the most bizarrely fun
moment of this episode David dreaming of
Sydney and the other patients in the
hospital doing this awesome Bollywood
style dance number and I love the little
detail of having the guy in the bush
dancing along with them so this song is
called poof Lola by sergey ginzburg in
1964 it means poor Lola named after
Lolita a famous book by Vladimir Nabokov
and it was made into a movie by Stanley
Kubrick actually feel like this song was
another track on that playlist that no
Holly made now when the interrogator
puts David in this electrified pool he
says these lines they came for you but
God
by accident we've got you but we want
her to so in case you're still left
wondering exactly what happened in this
episode here is an order of events as I
could best piece them together so David
is born in his abilities manifest as
mental problems and his adolescence then
David gets expelled from college tries
to kill himself and then gets
institutionalized and David meets Sydney
at the hospital who is secretly also a
mutant and she has the power to swap
minds with people that she touches so
they start dating and then on the day
Sydney gets released from the hospital
David kisses her and their minds switch
bodies David leaves the hospital in
Sidney's body while Sydney is left
behind a David's body and she freaks out
with these crazy powers and ends up
destroying the hospital and killing
Lenny meanwhile these other mutants
arrive to break David out and to recruit
him but they get Sydney by mistake since
she's the one in the hospital not David
then David's mind gets reunited with his
body and he stays with a sister and
looks for Sydney and then finally David
gets interrogated in this odd facility
while the mutant team now with Sydney on
board
hatches a plan to break him out and that
involves putana me the mutant with the
tommy gun using his power of memory
manipulation to project Sydney into
David's memory to instruct him about
their oncoming plan and I just love the
little details of the scene first
there's this black dog on a leash maybe
the same dog that we saw in the cage in
a monitoring room signaling to us that a
threat from these same people is
imminent also all the visuals indicate
that this memory is being manipulated
like the aspect ratio of the frame
changes to a more cinematic wide shot
making us doubt the reality of this
whole chase sequence and then notice how
right after Sydney professor quarrels -
David you can see a second David
starting to walk into this breezeway the
idea is that his memory is like a
recording that has had alterations made
to it which is exactly what Sydney and
putana me are doing okay so what exactly
goes down when David goes underwater now
if you look closely during the build-up
to this moment you can see little flames
appearing in the air and that air
becoming distorted as it gets heated and
the interrogator in the guards getting
all sweaty and uncomfortable so I think
that one of the mutants outside who's
rescuing David has the ability of
pyrokinesis making fire torching all the
air in this room leaving david safe
under water now this long take rescue
sequence that follow hose is one of the
most thrilling minute and 10 seconds
I've ever seen on television seriously
even if you were totally lost at this
point while watching the episode if this
part didn't win you over I don't know
what's wrong with you
you have no sense of joy and probably
the most exciting element of the
sequence is this mutant tossing around
guards and trucks and massive patches of
Earth like their playthings now some
people are saying that this guy could be
strife from the x-men comics who has a
similar power now I'm not sure about
that we'll see also I'm thinking that
this guy's telekinetic power is what
caused the detonator to fly out of the
interrogators hand in the previous scene
now just like the earlier long take that
we talked about this real-time sequence
even with it's surreal imagery is
suggesting that this is all real
objective truth this is actually
happening which Sydney confirms down on
the beach I have to know are you real
I'm real
this is Rio and in one last creepy cameo
the devil with the yellow eyes appears
in the bushes behind David he's a symbol
of David's nagging fear which David is
trying to leave behind in the battle as
he confronts the unknown with Melanie
bird and her team okay I think that
covers everything I noticed in Chapter
one of Legion but here are a few
lingering questions that I still have
one what is the time period this is all
taking place in it seems like it could
be in modern times but there's a major
60s vibe as well with Amy's wardrobe and
the three songs prominently featured in
the episode all being written in the 60s
- was Sydney ever even in the hospital
according to the interrogator and David
calling the hospital there's no record
of Sydney Barrett ever being a patient
now obviously Sydney seems like a real
person
like other people can see and interact
with her but there's clearly more to her
mystery that I'm hoping in future
episodes dig in 2 & 3 did David really
try to kill himself so dr. Kissinger
pointed out that on the day David
attempted suicide no noose was found
only rope burns on his neck so what does
that mean and what involvement did the
devil with the yellow eyes have in this
suicide attempt now obviously there's a
lot of mystery around the devil with the
yellow eyes and the broader mystery over
who exactly these interrogators are
along with that guy in the green suit
what's his deal but the fact that I
actually care and want to know the
answers to these questions is a
testament to how well-made this first
episode of Legion was now I really want
to make more videos about Legion as
future episodes come out but we're gonna
have to see how popular this show
becomes and how interested people are in
these mysteries and you can help by
sharing this video commenting keeping
the conversation going seriously let us
make Legion the show everyone is talking
about and if you like this video please
hit like and subscribe to new rockstars
and if you really like us you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current patrons especially
Kelly hopper you can hit me up on
Twitter at EA vas with any thoughts or
theories you had about Legion or follow
new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for info about when our videos
are coming out alright thanks for
watching bye
so silly
for sour